on the other extreme looking so bound
resources is sort of one extreme of
asymptotics availability the other is
perfectly reversible state and these are
states where the the rate of formation
and the rate of distillation are equal
so for the quantum case we know that
pure states have this but there's
actually a more general class of
reversible states so-called slag Pierre
station and these are just mixtures of
pure states where Alice and Bob can
determine which state they hold in that
mixture using locc and also Minshew and
I have done some work on studying the
classical analog of this and we've
identified a class of distributions that
have a classical flagged structure but
it's still open whether or not these are
the entirety of the reversible class of
states that have reversibility okay so
what I want to do in this talk is
actually add to another common feature
to these two resource series and this is
the question of round complexity and the
basic question is how does increased
rounds of interactive classical or
public communication enhance the ability
to process quantum or secret information
okay so just to discuss the previous
work done and actually to draw some
continuity to qi p of last year this was
a talk by a Braverman at all where they
considered the communication complexity
for the disjoint pneus problem and their
result is identifying a trade-off
between the number of rounds that you're
allowing of interaction and the amount
of communication you actually have to
perform and this is similar to some
previous work done where there's a type
of problem is studied where in r minus 1
round for a given problem you need a
certain amount of communication but if
you were allowed one more round you're
allowed you can achieve the problem with
substantially less communication but one
thing to note here is that this the type
of communication we're talking about
here is quantum communication so this is
sort of outside of the LLC CLO pc
framework
again we're interested in the in the
classical communication complexity okay
so some more previous results in in this
area where we're talking about llcc
round separation probably early on this
the BDS w paper where they look at
entanglement distillation they give a
nice example of state sets are distilled
vil using two-way llcc but are not the
syllable using one-way locc and I
pointed this this paper or this poster
that was given on monday or tuesday by
Levitsky and dada and smith where they
obtained some more results than one way
to steal ability and you can you can see
some examples of this so that's for
entanglement distillation for locc state
discrimination there's a number of
papers on this where there's a gap
between two way commute locc in one way
communication in particular this paper
shows a separation between are around
LCC and r minus 1 so in this paper shin
in duwon constructed in Samba love
states where if you're allowed our
rounds of LLC see you can perfectly
distinguish the elements of that in
Samba but with fewer rounds you're
unable to as far another task if you are
interested in multipartite system so
this would consider three parties and
you want to perform at lf-cc state
transformation there's been some work
that separates unbounded locc from from
finite round llcc so i kind of want to
pick up with with this last past care of
state transformation and i want to draw
your attention to an example that fails
to separate the round so here the task
is Allison Bob have some initial pure
state and they convert it into a mixed
state Sigma and they do this in our
round well it turns out that you can
always convert this around protocol into
a one-round protocol that achieves the
same transformation and so this was
first proven by it by low and possess Q
in 2001 and so the the message is that
for a pure state initial initial to a
mixed state final one round slices
and one thing I want to emphasize about
this result is that the round
compression holds for arbitrary
dimension okay so it doesn't matter what
your input or output dimensions on you
can always get this nice one round
compression and actually this this
result is absolutely crucial to proving
the major ization condition for
convertibility of pure states that that
we're familiar with because otherwise if
you if you weren't able to reduce it
down to one round it would become much
more much more complicated okay so so
this is that the result and then I think
a very natural question then is whether
the same thing holds for an initial
mixtape so if you have initially a mixed
a troll you also get a round compression
can you can you perform this in using
just one round of locc ok so our result
then is no you can't specifically for
every are there exists the state
transformation row to defy that needs
our rounds of locc to achieve so what
I'll do for the the next 10 minutes or
so is kind of go over the construction
of this and and the proof of how this
works so the states are constructed in
three steps and the first is we define a
probability distribution it's a
tripartite distribution call it D 1 and
it's easy to understand this
distribution if we just draw a picture
so the way to understand this is this
grid here we have Y so this is Bob's
variable on vertically X variable
horizontally and inside the grid those
values are Yves Yves variable and these
are eight equiprobable event so for
instance if we just look at this this
point here on the grid this is the event
that Alice holds to Bob holds y and eve
old one and because these are equal
probable others eight total events so
the probability of this event is 18 ok
so this is how we're going to represent
our distribution now this distribution
has some very nice properties and the
first is that if you're given Z and
Alice and Bob have one bit of perfectly
shared randomness so for any any value
of Z so for instance three you can see
that Alice and Bob have
have perfect shared randomness there so
this should get Alice involved very
excited because if they can determine
the using public communication without
leaking any in any information to eat
then they will have exactly one bit of
secret correlations and so actually
there's a protocol that does this and
maybe you can see it right away but it
goes as follows so Bob announces whether
his variable belongs to the set 0 1 or 2
3 and this has you can depict it like
this so it's either belongs to this this
red block or this green block now of
course even learns nothing about this
this communication right because she
already knows just looking at her
variable she knows whether she belongs
to green or red so she learns nothing
about it however Alice learned quite a
bit Zach Alice learns exactly the value
of y because within each block if you're
given X you can determine why exactly ok
so this is how Alice and Bob can can
obtain key just with this but remember
our goal is to build a quantum state so
the way that we do this is we now take
our distribution and we embed it into a
tripartite state so we introduce a
tripartite pure states where the
probability amplitudes are given by this
this distribution here and then what we
do is we traced out Eve and what we end
up having is a mixed stay here and each
size e in this mixture is maximally
entangled so using the classical
protocol that I described in the
previous slide we can turn this into a
one-way locc protocol as follows so in
the first round Bob projects in the 01
subspace of the 23 subspace he
communicates that to Alice and then
given that outcome Alice knows where to
project right so if it's in the 01
subspace Alex either projects it hurt in
2012 the 23 on the other hand if it's in
the Bob projection the 23 then Alice has
to choose a different projector but the
point isn't that each of these branches
they obtain a maximally entangled state
so you with a one-way protocol we're
able to distill this mixed state into an
EP our state's perfectly
okay so this was just for one way now
what we'll do is we it reiterates this
so we use this as our basic building
block and we build up so here we went
from b1 to b2 so what we do is we take a
copy of this and we do a permutation so
we permute the rows here and at each
level we add these alphabets size has
doubled and also one of the parties is
doubled so you can see from b1 we made a
copy we double the eve variables then to
get from be two to be three we just take
this make a copy of it and you have b2 +
b2 bar and then you get before you take
b3 you make a copy of it etc and
actually so this looks extremely
complicated but it has a tremendous
amount of structure because what we're
doing it at each level of this is we're
copying the structure from the previous
round and just shifting things into a
disjoint a disjoint set is a way to
think about it so we've called these
origami distributions because it has a
structure that you are kind of folding
the distributions to build up okay so
then the quantum state is obtained in
the same way that we embed these
distributions into a tripartite state
and then we trace out trace out Eve and
you can obtain in our rounds of locc you
can attain a maximum tangled State just
by undoing this folding process so the
protocol is exactly similar to that the
one round protocol except now we've just
carried it out for our our rounds so
it's not too hard to see that our rounds
of L sec suffice to do this
transformation but the major question is
what about if you have fewer than our
rounds can you still perform this
transformation and the answer to this is
no this is this is sort of our results
and to prove this I can just describe it
the key observation is the following
that and this holds the first point
holds in general for any mixed
transformation to a pure state if you
want to do this perfectly you have to
transform every state in the mixture to
your target state okay so that's the
first thing that we need is we have to
transform each of the size ease into in
25 in this in this protocol the next
observation is that because each of
these
these are maximally entangled they have
ashram it rank of two okay and the
Schmidt rank itself isn't in SLO CC
monotone so that s locc is stochastic
locc and so what that means is that if
at any point in the protocol the Schmidt
rank drops it can never be increased
again with any nonzero probability and
this has a very strong consequence
because we know that each of these must
be converted into maximally entangled
states so at each round of the
measurement the size II must either be
eliminated or emit rank remains the same
it can't decrease down to 1 because once
you have one you can't convert it into
an entangled State and actually this is
the essential ingredient in the proof
that justice this observation that at
each round sighs you must be eliminated
or Schmidt rank remains the same and it
actually forces Alice and Bob to perform
the correct measurement sequences to
give you a flavor of why this is so
let's consider an example so here's the
distribution be three ok now let's
suppose that alice is going to be the
measuring party and suppose she wants to
eliminate sy1 okay so that's that's this
guy here in our in the way we've sort of
drawn these distributions so what will
she have to do to eliminate this well
she's going to have to eliminate her
local subspace spanned by it by two and
three that's the only way she can
eliminate that state however when it's
such an outcome were to occur that she
projects into the orthogonal complement
of this guy so that two three is
eliminated what's happened is that
you've decrease the the rank of these
other states side to side 35 14 by 11
5399 so a way to think about that is it
these are note there's no entanglement
left in these states on the post
measurement state after Alice makes that
measurement ok so but but this of course
is not allowed because of this
constraint so the only way that that she
could avoid this is actually if she were
to eliminate all of these states but
doing so would cause her to eliminate
everything and this is not possible so
the concluded here is that Alex cannot
eliminate any states in the mixture if
she were to measure in this particular
distribution here okay so how would just
be avoided well so Alice can't do
anything so we have to throw it back to
Bob and there is something Bob can do
here Bob can just measure in in the 0 1
2 3 sub space or the 0 4 5 6 7 subspace
so when he makes this so he either
projects here or here and you see that
we haven't destroyed any of the Schmidt
rank in this in this measurement here so
this is this is still an allowed thing
but what have we done you see we've
taken our B 3 and what remains is
something that's that's equivalent to be
too so it's up to up to a national OCC
transformation it's essentially be too
so this constraint is forced Bob to play
fairly how we want them to place its
force them to make the proper unfolding
to go from from be 32 to be too okay so
so this is just the example you can
imagine now doing this for four are
round and so if we started off with with
roll are at the end of our minus one
round we would go from from roll BR down
to roby one and something that's it
that's up to an equivalent at the low CC
equivalents but it's not difficult to
show that if you have this and you're
allowed no further communication you
cannot turn this into a maximally
entangled state pure state so if r minus
1 rounds you're unable to do it then you
actually you do need our around to make
this transformation again the idea is it
just sort of showing that if you have
fewer than are around you end up in a
situation where you can't obtain a
maximally entangled state okay so that's
sort of the the rough idea of the of the
proof for the classical for the quantum
problem but now I want to consider the
analogous classical problem okay so here
the goal for alice and bob is now
thinking classically they want to obtain
secret key so we want to have a similar
sort of lower bound on the on the amount
of communication they must do so in the
question is how many rounds of LPC does
it take allison Bob to make this
transformation so in the in the quantum
case the proof realize
crucially on on the Schmidt rank and the
fact that it's a stochastic monotone so
the question is what is the classical
analog of Schmidt rank and if we can
somehow if we can somehow define
something or find an object that behaves
similar to the quantum Schmidt rank then
we will be able to quickly answer this
question okay so this is a quantity that
we call the secrecy rank and to kind of
motivate it a bit let's go back to a
decomposition of a bipartite pure state
so one way you can think about the
Schmidt rank of the state is it's the
minimum number of product states whose
span contains five right you can't
express five as a linear combination of
any fewer products states then it's it's
Schmidt rank so now suppose that Alice
and Bob measure their their state Phi in
the schmidt basis so they'll generate
some distribution that has this this
form here so these are the Delta
function and its alpha Bob have
perfectly correlated out output and with
some distribution pw which was just the
schmidt coefficients in ok but one way
you can think about this this particular
distribution is it has this the
structure that there exists some
auxiliary variable W such that x and y
are independent given w now in this case
it's somewhat trivial because w is equal
to x and y so it that this Markov chain
holds trivially but but nevertheless
it's one type of distribution that has
this property and this is what we
identify is being sort of the defining
property of the secrecy rank so we
propose this definition first
considering an uncorrelated distribution
where Eva's is out of the picture so we
want to minimize overall auxiliary
variables that render x and y
independence and this is just the the
range of W ok so it's a number of events
where W has nonzero probability ok so
this is fine this is how we define for
an uncorrelated Eve but but what about
for a correlated Eve all right so now
again we're going to go back to the
quantum scenario and we're too
for some sort of intuition on how to how
to define this and recall the definition
of ashram it rank for a bipartite mixed
state now so this is proposed by terho
and her dekhi and the way to think about
this is for a mixed state you you look
at all possible in zombo's that realize
pure state and sambas that realize the
mixture and in each of the in samba love
you compute the mitt rank of you compute
the maximum it ranked among all the
states in the in samba okay so with this
this definition in mind let's go to the
tripartite distribution and we can think
of this we can think of a distribution
px Y Z as defining an in Samba love
bipartite distribution right so for
every ever easy we get another another
bipartite distribution px Y Z so with
this in mind we dispose the following
definition of a secrecy rank that has
the same structure that we look at the
secrecy rank of the bipartite
distribution maximized overall Z you see
unlike in the quantum case we don't have
this freedom of it this we don't have to
do a minimization over in Samba because
classically there is only one in Samba
for your your distribution so we don't
have this minimization here ok so here's
that there's another form of it ok so
we've now established this this
correspondence between secrecy rank and
schmidt rank and the main property is
that the secrecy rank is an SLO PC
monotone so just like Schmidt rank is a
SLO CC monotone secrecy rank is a so
cast Okello p.m. on its own and what
that means is that for any sequences of
messages in your protocol you cannot the
secrecy rank is monotonically decreasing
so with this quantity established the
the quantum proof translates literally
verbatim into the classical setting and
we're able to derive a lower bound on on
the transformation of a tripartite
distribution into a secret key so this
if we start off with BR you you need our
rounds of LPC to do that ok so just to
get to some conclusions here so here's
our main result is that we have this
analogous structural result between the
the quantum locc in classical ello PC
actually we're able to give us somewhat
of a slider it's like strengthening so
for any are you can there exists some
non 0 epsilon that you can get that you
are unable to get within epsilon close
to your target states in in fewer than
then are around and this follows just
from a compactness of locc and
compactness of elbow PC and also we can
we can generalize in another way so
since everything is based on this notion
of ranks we can consider partially
entangled States and weakly correlated
secret key and we're able to show this
that for any for every are in any any
lambda between zero and one half this
this transformation also requires our
rounds of LLC C&L pc now what's
interesting is if somewhat interesting
maybe but if you take lambda to be zero
of course what happens so it when lambda
0 you have no entanglement here and you
have no shared correlation there so of
course you don't need you can do that in
zero around these are free states in
your resource theory so you have this
sort of this discontinuity in round
number so as lambda approaches posted 0
you need our rounds to do this
transformation but when lambda is equal
to zero you can do it in in zero around
okay so I'll just end with some open
questions and future work so first of
all just some main drawbacks of our
approaches that the dimension scales
poorly to to dr and the size here so the
natural question is can we find examples
with bounded dimension and i said this
with some slight strengthening that we
can get that we have restriction on how
close you can get you can't get with an
epsilon but at the moment we have no way
to actually lower bound this this
epsilon except just saying that there
exists some non 0 epsilon another
interesting question is for asymptotic
transformations okay so here we have n
copies and we want to go to M copies and
we want to know what rates are
achievable so we can ask what is the
hour round asymptotic distillation of
both our mixed state and our our
distribution and
maybe an intriguing question is if we
consider asymptotically do we get some
sort of round compression right so maybe
you can you can distill at a rate you
can still a silt distill one key or of
one bit of key or one a bit and fewer
than our round and a final note is that
these states that we've created actually
the entanglement cost and the Distilled
oh entanglement are equal and actually
this is what sort of motivated us to
construct the distribution because we
were studying this reversibility problem
and and what this says is that
asymptotic entanglement reversibility
may require our around protocol is to
actually distill at optimal rate and
thus the states with reversible
entanglement can have very complex
structure so this is some additional
work that will be done and data thank
you very much questions Todd
do we have people with microphones Wow
earn your keep mark you're going to make
you fit this way yeah so can you
construct so I'm interested it could go
to an asymptotic limit in a different
sense in the number of rounds right so
could you construct an example where you
want to transform a row to a sigma and
you can't do so exactly in any finite
number of rounds but you can approximate
it better and better with more and more
rounds yes so well for for bipartite
systems yeah actually yes we have
examples of this for both tripartite ear
States and 44 bipartite states as well
where exactly what you said you need as
you as you allow more and more rounds
you can get closer and closer but in the
limit in the limit you can do it but for
any finite you cannot obtain it yes
and the other questions so I'm wondering
if you have further applications of this
quantity that you called secrecy rank oh
that's a great great question yeah so
this this this quantity here was it so
this is something similar that appears
in an older paper by in the classical
literature by whiner and it's when he
introduces something known as the common
information for a about two variables
and what whiner does is he considers a
similar minimization overall auxiliary
variable variables that leave x and y
independent but the quantity that you're
minimizing over is the mutual
information between x y and w okay so
it's similar in flavor to that in that
where we're interested in this variable
W but instead of measuring the mutual
information we just want to know the
range of it but you could consider and
this is something to answer your
question that I'm interested in is
studying all different types of entropic
quantities on that side and
understanding w in different settings as
well so you could put other quantities
in there like besides rank and mutual
information sure like you look at the
the entropy of W and that would give you
something and and I'm almost positive
that that would also be a monotone so we
give you a secret in monotone as well
any sort of rainy entropy like what
properties would you need for the
resulting quantity to be a monotone like
I mean there you have rank and you
mentioned mutual information what
property would you need for that
quantity and therefore it to be a
secrecy monitor you know yes okay so
this is just my intuition here but this
is w the way I think of this w is
somehow being similar to the Schmidt
coefficients in a bipartite state and so
just as we can define entanglement
monotone as functions of our Schmidt
coefficients I feel confident that this
w will also have it so this goes back to
some of the
work by like get free badal where he
just characterizes general entanglement
monotones based on the Schmidt
coefficients using certain properties so
I think something similar can be done
with his W yeah yeah
thank you so this is just to clarify so
do we know like if we put a bound on the
dimension can it still be that we need
more and more ram 444 tripartite system
yes that is true we do have examples of
that but for for examples like this a
bipartite mixed appears transformations
don't know and what do you suspect uh
yeah I think I suspect that you can find
something like this yep okay let's thank
Eric again
[Applause]